No cameras were allowed in the court
yesterday which is typical in federal
cases but a handful of reporters were
inside including our very own Scott
McFarland Scott good morning so what did
you see in the courtroom
today good morning Trump showed little
expression on his face he was hunched
over at the defense table he had his
arms crossed was rarely taking notes and
rarely speaking to attorneys on either
side of him in fact it was his defense
attorney who entered the not guilty plea
this was a mirror image to what I saw in
the courtroom weeks ago in Manhattan in
the front row yesterday was special
counsel Jack Smith we saw watch Trump's
every move as the former president
exited the courtroom after the
arraignment we didn't see Trump look
back sitting behind Trump in the rows
behind him were a number of his
supporters who won a lottery to get
seats in the courtroom for this historic
day we also met a California dad an
attorney who was in town for his
daughter's basketball camp who decided
to camp out overnight to try to win his
seat in the courtroom for the historic
day and he did next question when is the
next Hearing in this case it's not
scheduled yet we're also not sure if it
stays here in Miami or moves to the
federal courthouse in West Palm Beach
which is nearest to Mar-A-Lago Tony
all right Scott thank you very much